E aí
eu
quero ver a minha vermelho e
E aí
Oi Eita
senhoras e senhores agora porque a honra
neste grande evento desse dar um grande
número de mágica pra vocês esses números
de mágica chama assim os quatro
elementos da natureza vejam Bem eu
trouxe aqui quatro lenços representando
os quatro elementos da natureza Olha o
amarelo representa o ar
EA água
é
muito bem muito bem o verde representar
a terra
é horrível pouco
muito bem e o azul o bem mais precioso
do nosso planeta água
e combinando rapidamente pois nós
estamos numa Corrida Contra o Tempo e
quando o contato é fez Todo mundo vai
falar comigo ou a palavra mágica viva a
natureza ou 23
e agora senhores é
E aí
é
muito bem mas não para por aí a gente
vai agora
uma corrida contra o tempo água do nosso
planeta do Rio Meia Ponte Capituba Vaca
Brava Tietê aqui muito bem agora vamos
então
ao vivo EA cores
Olá sejam bem senhoras e senhores vamos
ouvir agora não silêncio total
alô cinoplasta
vamos ouvir o canto da água do nosso
planeta
E aí
Oi Jaque somos campeões e campeãs em
planta poluem o planeta em destruir em
nome do capitalismo a gente vai agora
mostrar que somos seres humanos
civilizados porque tá cheio de doutorado
mestrado civilizado e o planeta todo
regassado bem vamos todos no gesto
Ecológico triplicar as mãos para o rumo
da água e tudo que eu tô falando vocês
vão repetindo comigo
e
fala casa no cabelo
o pé de pato Pé de Pano night
eu tô sempre tir
concentrar it a Secret
reciclagem quanto mais olhar ET
mais enxergar it
Oi e o planeta só se lasca
senhoras e senhores quando eu contar até
três todo mundo fala comigo a palavra
mágica viva a natureza 23
oi oi
E aí
e
obrigado senhor senhores espetáculo para
continuar o planeta girando um
E aí